over the past few weeks a korean league
of legends caster
has deleted his twitter had his
grandmother doxxed
and caused a protest involving a truck
with a giant
billboard driving around seoul korea all
because he
might be the next coach of t1's league
of legends team
look i can't make this [ __ ] up
[Music]
look if you're not subscribed to the
channel yet what are you doing
scroll down subscribe to the channel hit
that like button and leave a comment on
the video
letting us know what you think of this
latest league of legends drama
also if you've got a story for us the
don't at me team you can hit us up at
our email
tips at thescore.com okay so back at the
beginning of november
news leaked that t1 you know that league
team that faker plays for
had signed a former starcraft pro named
polt
and an lck caster named ls as part of
their
coaching staff for 2021 t1's support
effort was streaming at the time and he
accidentally leaked a discord
conversation in korean
that suggested that the two men had been
signed to be the new coaches of the most
decorated team
in league history now you might think
that news like this
would be welcomed with open arms t1
missed worlds this year and they
definitely need to make some changes if
they want to compete with the likes of
world champions dam one gaming
in the lck next year so some new coaches
should be a good thing right well not in
the eyes of the t1 fan base
you see ls and polt are stepping in to
fill the shoes
once filled by the likes of coma in the
teams hayden
not only widely accepted as the best
coach
in the history of league of legends but
i think you could make an argument for
him being one of the best coaches
in the history of any esport like any
game
immediately the resumes of polt and
ls were called into question apparently
a starcraft pro
and a caster were not good enough for
the t1 fans
and because ls has a bit of a
controversial past
and is the most prominent public figure
in this situation
he got a ton of hate on social media
fans took
issue with his outspoken reputation it's
no secret that
ls is not afraid to speak his mind in
korea
specifically during his time coaching
the bbq olivers
when he actually got into it with t1's
untar according to what did on twitter
that incident is actually one of the
only things that korean
speaking league of legends fans know
about ls
so i guess you could understand them
having a little bit of a bad taste in
the method
and fans were quick to let them know
that they were not cool with him being
the next coach of t1
now obviously we don't do an episode of
this show
every time someone in the esports world
gets hate on twitter
what's truly insane about this situation
is the extent to which the korean fans
have gone to
to voice their displeasure after the
news leaked there was a report on reddit
that korean fans literally fundraised
a truck with a digital billboard on it
and drove it outside of t1's
headquarters look
i didn't believe it at first either but
we've got pictures
the truck read quote we the t1 fans
demand a clear
and detailed explanation from top
management end quote these people
really were not happy and it didn't stop
there fans also sent
bouquets of flowers mourning the death
of t1's league of legends team to the
headquarters of t1 in seoul
and what's worse is that it actually got
even messier
and this is the part of the story that's
not so funny
reports came out that outraged fans had
doxxed
ls's grandmother and were harassing her
fanatic's mid laner nemesis actually
talked about the situation on stream
recently
no i was in a call with alice um
he's in a really bad spot apparently
he's
now his grandmother is being harassed
and stuff like this
and people are trying to do really bad
things to him
like this whole ordeal with the truck
now
that's a good bit but this grandmother
situation
is [ __ ] up and after all the dust
settled on this ls decided to delete his
twitter entirely now as this mess was
unfolding
t1 finally spoke up on the matter and
released
this statement on twitter quote dear
fans we would like to take a moment to
address the speculations that are
circulating in our communities
we are aware of the concerns that have
surfaced during the league of legends
rebuilding process
and we want to reassure our fans that we
are working hard to implement a coaching
structure
that will position us to win and bring
home a 2021
world championship we kindly ask for
your patience as we consult with our
players and staff to carry out the best
strategy
for the future of our organization we
appreciate your continued love and
support for t1
and look forward to sharing our official
announcements soon
end quote now obviously that statement
didn't confirm
at all that polt and ls were hired
as was suggested on effort stream so i
guess they leave themselves the option
of going with new coaches now that all
of this has popped off and everyone's
upset
which sure is good for the organization
from a cosmetic standpoint
but let's get real here holt and ls
are the real victims of the situation
assuming they were actually hired for
the gig
this isn't exactly the resounding
welcome
that you would hope for now since t1
statement on twitter
many members of the league of legends
community have spoken up in support of
ls on twitter
including papa smithy and i will
dominate and taking a more neutral
position
was evil geniuses head coach peter dunn
who sheds some light on the lack of
experience that t1 fans are frustrated
and of course there is some value in
trying to put yourself
in the position of a t1 die hard but
let's get real here for a second i don't
care if t1
went out onto the street in seoul found
some random guy
handed him hundreds of thousands of
dollars and asked him to make faker a
god again
i'm not gonna go harass his grandmother
and all jokes aside it's not like t1
are hiring faceless nobodies here ls
may be controversial but he has an
entrenched position
inside the korean league of legends and
is widely loved
for his analysis of one of the most
competitive leagues in
all of esports and like let's look at
traditional sports
it's not like in basketball they take
the most recently retired hall of famer
and make him the head coach of the
lakers you don't see
shaq running up and down the sidelines
as the coach and for a little bit more
context
travis gafford and mark z actually
discussed the potential implications of
this move
on a recent episode of hotline league i
i don't know if it's the biggest move in
league history but it's definitely
gonna be a very talked about one it's
one of those moves where i don't think
anyone will ever
talk about it in a middle ground sense
because we in part because ls no one
ever talks about in a middle ground
sense
ls is just a controversial figure people
either love or hate him already just as
a commentator uh see you know
i expect when there's performance behind
that
that will continue even to a larger
degree look there is a
lot of pressure as we can see on t1 to
perform
so they went out and did something
unconventional
to try to get some new results this is
exactly what we're asking
league of legends teams in north america
to do
go out and make institutional markedly
different decisions than you've made in
the past in order to change the future
why don't we just let t1 do that
dude if if you had a giant truck with
like a billboard what would you put on
it
like it's like could you imagine like
imagine all of the ways that you could
like voice your displeasure
with something like it's [ __ ] 20 20
man everyone's on the internet
like why what compels you to like spa
i mean it had to have cost like a lot of
money to do that like what compels you
to be like
this this is the way that we're gonna
get their intention
attention we're just gonna drive this
truck around in a circle for hours